und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend fangen wir mit unseren
ungeliebten dauerthema an rund 23.800
gemeldeten neuinfektionen die inzidenz
260,7 einige bundesländer kommen jetzt
der bundes notbremse zuvor die sich noch
auf dem gesetzesweg befindet eine der
umstrittenen punkte dabei bleibt das
schulthema was inzwischen nicht mehr
geht so zu tun als hätten kinder ein
magisches schutzschild das hat man ja
das ganze letzte jahr hindurch immer
wieder gehört kinder seien angeblich
nicht infektiös gestimmt hat das von
anfang an nicht
das war aber vielleicht komfortabler
daran zu glauben
statt sich dem problem zu stellen seit
bei 117 in großbritannien durch die
schulen und kitas rauschte und die
studienlage dank systematischer testung
da eindeutig ist hat sich diese debatte
erledigt und manchen kultusministern
dämmert sogar dass auch kinder von longo
wird betroffen sein können
nun kommt noch ein neues incident
problem hinzu über diese diskussion
berichtet kamran safari
sie sollen schließen wenn die cds an
drei tagen hintereinander die 200er
marke überschreitet schulen
deutschlandweit so sieht es die geplante
notbremse vor doch der wert bezieht sich
auf die inzidenz der gesamtbevölkerung
bei kindern liegt der wert oft viel
höher
während in 100 der 400 1 kreisen und
städten deutschlands die inzidenz bei
über 200 liegt liegt sie bei den fünf
bis 14 jährigen in 170 kreisen und
städten über 200 warum ist die inzidenz
bei kindern so hoch mit dem auftreten
der britischen variante ist die chance
einer eins zu eins übertragung einfach
höher geworden bisher waren das immer
die super special events die
hauptsächlich bei erwachsenen
aufgetreten sind jetzt steckt man sich
mehr wirklich von einer person auf die
andere an und das ist in den schulen
relevant wo sich die kinder
untereinander anstecken können
und das natürlich auch relevant wenn ein
kind was sich angesteckt hat nach hause
kommt und dann in der familie das virus
weiter gibt
drei beispiele wie hoch die inzidenz bei
kindern im vergleich zur allgemein
inzidenz ist in schwerin liegt sie in
allen altersklassen bei 177 bei den fünf
bis 14 jährigen ist sie fast dreimal so
hoch ähnlich im kreis birkenfeld in
rheinland-pfalz gesamt incidents 127 bei
kindern 381 und die bayrischen würzburg
ist der inzidenz wert bei kindern mehr
als doppelt so hoch der lehrerverband
fordert bei schulschließungen jetzt eine
altersspezifische inzidenz unter 200
also die 200 sind eindeutig viel zu hoch
man muss sich außerdem anderen
altersspezifischen instanzen orientieren
wenn jugendliche bei 4 500 liegen aber
die gesamtbevölkerung erst bei 150 dann
sind trotzdem schon öffnungen auf keinen
fall gerechtfertigt trotz steigender
infektionszahlen wollen nordrhein
westfalen und baden württemberg ab
montag die schulen teilweise öffnen
in nrw haben jetzt über zehn kommunen
mit einer inzidenz von über 200
vorzeitig die notbremse gezogen
ulm und stuttgart in baden württemberg
empfehlen dass auch experten fordern
daher eine frühere notbremse bei schulen
wir fordern dass die notbremse von 100
auch für schulen gilt dass der wechsel
in den distanz unterricht bei 100 greift
ausnahmen sollten nur möglich sein wenn
die impfung von lehrkräften weit
fortgeschrittenes bzw
eine konsequente tests licht regelmäßige
tests pflicht gilt ansonsten sind die
200 nicht verantwortbar andernfalls so
meidinger drohen schulen zu infektions
treibern zu werden
wie hoch die inzidenz bei den fünf bis
14 jährigen in ihrem landkreis ist zeigt
eine interaktive deutschlandkarte auf
zdf heute und in der heute app die union
startete derweil weiter auf ihr k-frage
dilemma wie das kaninchen auf die
schlange
man sei im konstruktiven gesprächen
heißt es aus den parteizentralen
aber so irre konstruktiv werden die wohl
nicht sein sonst gäbe es ja eine lösung
umso mehr fällt auf wie anders die
grünen mit ihrem cadu l umgehen leicht
fällt die entscheidung dort auch nicht
aber man hört kein wirklich böses wort
übereinander
man hört eigentlich gar nichts und eine
basis befragung ist auch nicht
vorgesehen
die parteiführung wurde gewählt auch um
führungsfragen zu klären so konservativ
sieht man dass offenkundig bei den
grünen die sich einst gerne selbst
zerlegte
am montag soll verkündet werden wer
antritt passen sagt berichtet eigentlich
ist es nur ein ganz normaler
nominierungsparteitag der grünen im rat
einigen burgen annalena baerbock soll
hierzu spitzenkandidatin gewählt werden
nicht zur kanzlerkandidatin dennoch
redet die grünen-vorsitzende wie eine
die ins zentrum der macht will
dafür treten wir dafür trete ich im
september an für eine erneuerung unseres
landes zum ersten mal in ihrer
geschichte kämpfen die grünen um platz
eins bei der bundestagswahl mit aller
macht wollen sie an die macht
ich will die grünen in die regierung
führen deutschland ist zu lange schon
nicht durch die grünen regiert worden
und das war nicht gut für dieses land
das muss sich jetzt ändern das wollen
wir ändern
seit wochen wird spekuliert wer
kanzlerkandidat der grünen wird robert
habeck war lange liebling der medien
bringt regierungserfahrung mit
als er und berbalk 2018 zum ersten mal
an die parteispitze gewählt wurden war
das wahrnehmungs gefälle zugunsten habe
es noch groß tatsächlich hat berbalk in
der innerparteilichen und medialen
aufmerksamkeit gegenüber habeck mächtig
aufgeholt in sache und detailfragen ist
sie häufig tritt fester als ihr
ko-vorsitzender und die
geschlechterfrage spielt bei den grünen
auch heute noch eine große rolle
wenn anna lena berger als frau sagen
würde ich mache ist weil ich eine frau
bin und die frauen haben das erste
zugriffsrecht dann hat sie es natürlich
früher waren streit und basisdemokratie
teil der grünen identität vor jahren
noch hätte ein hinterzimmer entscheidung
der doppelspitze den unmut der basis
provoziert heute gehört geschlossenheit
ganz offenbar zur grünen partei saison
ich wünsche mir dass robert weil ich
persönlich kenne aber ich sehe dass anna
lena genauso den job machen können
die beiden machen im vergleich zu da und
lächelt
es ist diese neue geschlossenheit die es
auch ermöglichen soll
das anders als bei anderen parteien der
unterlegene nicht als verlierer dasteht
unabhängig davon also wer einen halben
schritt zurück geht und wer dann diese
kandidatur übernimmt werde ich teil des
spitzenteams in berlin sein und einen
bundespolitischen wahlkampf führen
wir werden gemeinsam diesen wahlkampf
auch im team und gemeinsam mit unserer
parteien gern zu führen annalena
baerbock und robert habeck sind zwei die
ganz nach oben wollen
am montag werden sie bekanntgeben wer
von ihnen sich fürs kanzleramt empfehlen
darf dass das nach der bundestagswahl
tatsächlich kommt glauben auch bei den
grünen nicht alle aber die aussichten
waren schon mal schlechter
[Musik]
ob es jetzt noch teils weiter mit
anderen nachricht des tages
der frühere unionsfraktionschef und
unterlägen der bewerber um den
cdu-vorsitz friedrich merz ist für die
bundestagswahl vom kreisverband des
hochsauerlandkreises zu dessen
direktkandidaten gewählt worden
die abstimmung im sauerländischen
arnsberg fand gruner bedingt auf der
tribüne eines fussball stadions statt
märz setzte sich dabei gegen den
aktuellen cdu-bundestagsabgeordneten
sensburg durch vor dem hintergrund
wachsender spannungen mit china haben
die usa ihre sicherheitsgarantie für
japan erneuert inklusive des einsatzes
von atomwaffen im bedarfsfall das schutz
versprechen gilt nach angaben der
us-regierung auch für die von japan
kontrolliert ist in cargo inselgruppe im
ostchinesischen meer
die china ebenfalls für sich beansprucht
der japanische ministerpräsident sogar
war als erster ausländischer
regierungschef seit dem amtsantritt von
präsident biden zu einem treffen im
weißen haus
beide warnten vor chinas ausweitung von
gebietsansprüchen zugleich äußerten sie
sorge über pekings hartes durchgreifen
in hongkong und gegen muslimische
uiguren will kind inmitten der
spannungen zwischen russland und der
ukraine hat das heute eine gegenseitige
ausweisung von diplomaten gegeben
das russische außenministerium teilte
mit der ukrainische konsul in sankt
petersburg müsse das land verlassen
ihm wurde vorgeworfen er habe versucht
an geheime informationen zu gelangen die
ukraine reagierte mit der ausweisung
eines russischen diplomaten in russland
hat 15 kriegsschiffe für ein manöver ins
schwarze meer geschickt sie hätten heute
die meerenge von kertsch an der
halbinsel krim passiert teilte die
marine der agentur interfax zufolge mit
wie lange die übungen dauern wurde
zunächst nicht gesagt
nach einem halben jahr im all sind drei
raumfahrer sicher zur erde zurückgekehrt
die nasa astronautin und die beiden
russischen kosmonauten landeten mit
ihrer sojus-kapsel in der kasachischen
steppe
ein halbes jahr hatten die drei an bord
der internationalen raumstation iss
verbracht und dort hatten sie etwa 400
kilometer über der erde zahlreiche
experimente durchgeführt
eine meldung aus der fußball bundesliga
da galt das interesse heute neben den
spielen auch eine personalentscheidung
von bayern münchens trainer hansi flick
er habe dem verein gesagt dass er am
ende der saison den vertrag auflösen
möchte gawlik heute bekannt mehr dazu
und zu den spielen gleich im aktuellen
sportstudio und jetzt die lottozahlen
dieses samstags sie lauten wie immer
ohne gewähr
18 22 25 26 36 48 superzahl 0
und weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotter punkt zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 6 die wetteraussichten für
morgen im norden und westen scheint am
vormittag oft die sonne sonst bleiben
die wolken meist dicht und vor allem in
der mitte gibt es schauer gewitter sind
auch möglich die temperatur steigt auf 6
bis 15 grad
auch in den nächsten tagen gibt es
schauer und gewitter
allerdings nehmen die sonnen anteile zu
es wird auch langsam wärmer haben
mittwoch bis 18 grad
es war die königin die heute offiziell
abschied von ihrem prinzgemahl nahm ein
nationaler trauerakt aber es war auch
eine frisch verwitwete die in den store
in der kapelle saß seine traurige
ehefrau die auf 73 gemeinsame jahre
zurückblickt als oliver passieren
philipp kennenlernte war es liebe auf
den ersten blick eine eheschließung aber
mit hindernissen nicht jeder im
königreich war über ihre wahl begeistert
und für philipp war es alles andere als
leicht eine queen durchs leben zu
begleiten und ihrer krönung die früher
kam als beide gehofft hatten endete die
unbeschwerte zeit der zweisamkeit aber
sie halten durch was auch sonst und
erfüllten ihre pflichten ohne seinen
schrägen humor wäre die krone sicher
noch schwerer zu tragen gewesen über die
trauerfeier heute berichtet andreas
stamm
gott schütze die queen wohl niemals
wahrer als an diesem tag die einsame
königin trauert um ihren mann um eine
liebe die mehr als acht jahrzehnte
umspannte ihre wie elisabeth selbst
anmerkte stärke und stütze ist gegangen
die die sich trotz der bitte wegen
corona schloss windsor fernzubleiben
versammeln und eine sorge ob monats ist
oder nicht
es dürfte eher das herz brechen mir
bricht es das schon beim zuschauen
manchmal wenn die liebe des lebens geht
stirbt auch die andere person wenige
wochen später ich hoffe die queen stirbt
nicht auch noch ganz ehrlich ganz winter
fühlt mit der queen jeder hier spürt was
wir mit philipp verlieren aber er wollte
sicher nicht das betreue ich sind dass
er wollte eine trauerfeier nach seinen
vorstellungen prinz philip hatte sie
jahrelang minutiös geplant seine liebe
zum militär bestimmt die prozession des
sargs im innenhof von schloss windsor
in einem nach seinen vorstellungen
umgebauten landrover geht es auf die
letzte reise dahinter die engste familie
der bruderzwist zwischen william und
harry über rassismus gefühlskälte und
die königliche familie als eine art
gefängnis für einen moment vergessen wie
auch die ewige sorge über die zukunft
der monarchie eine kleine feier kein
staatsbegräbnis das war phillips wunsch
das kleine wirkt dann doch groß kunst
der inszenierung in bester britischer
tradition mit einer schweigeminute
landauf landab
das ist so klein wurde mit nur 30 gästen
in der st george's chapel einem mini
chor corona geschuldet trotz masken
pflicht steht die trauer über den
verlust des familienoberhaupt in den
gesichtern geschrieben das große und
ganze betont der erzbischof von
canterbury dass es neben trauer um die
würdigung der lebensleistung eines mit
99 friedlich verstorbenen geht
wir danken so herr für seinen
entschlossenen glauben sein hohes maß an
pflichtbewusstsein und integrität für
philips leben im dienste der nationen es
kamen nur auf für seinen mut und
inspiration der sarg verschwindet in der
gruft symbolisiert durch den gegenden
dudelsackspieler der herzog von
edinburgh wird dort aufgebahrt bis er an
der seite seiner frau im familiengrab
seine letzte ruhestätte finden wird möge
das noch lange dauern so die hoffnung im
darin vereinigten königreich gott
schütze die queen das war es von uns die
kollegen vom sportstudio freuen sich
wenn sie dran bleiben der einiges los in
der bundesliga und gegen 0.25 gibt es
dann die nächste heute express mit uns
morgen wieder bis dahin auf wiedersehen
[Musik]